how can single men overcome anxiety or
fear of rejection in the dating world
I'll answer that one yeah I literally I
think single men need to actually
partner with other men men like myself
men like yourself and actually learn
from other men and I think they need to
get to the bottom of why that's
happening with they need to do with
their own mindset
it's literally because it's rejection
right he said for me rejection is all
about what you make it mean it's not the
rejection it's the meaning that you
described to that rejection what do you
make that mean I'm not good enough I'm
not tall enough I'm not rich enough as
opposed to it's just one person so it
really is cultivating an abundance
mindset there are so many women and
great people out there and once you've
got an abundant mindset it's a bit I
don't know it's like
I don't know it's like I don't know
going to McDonald's and they run out of
your burger do you get upset by it you
go and find another one isn't it right
well you missed the bus you wait for
another one why is it when it comes to
other human beings we feel oh my God
that's rejected it's just okay one
person rejected you now if you're really
clever you might find that why that
might be somewhere to start if you're
great just enough why did you reject me
go and catch a person you're too short
or you're this or your breath things
whatever find out whatever it is be be
courageous they're too short there's
nothing you can do about it so have the
courage to accept things you can't
change that's fine but there are plenty
of very confident charismatic short guys
out there getting women so it's not the
short thing it's it's who you're being
you know what's interesting just being
on social media and like having people
mess it like you know sometimes I do
one-on-ones or sometimes people message
me with like problems or whatever I
found that men are so much more willing
to take feedback than women true where
it's like if a woman if you even imply
it's something with her for the reason
that she's single it's like all hell
breaks loose like I always say this like
if you're single the men you want don't
want you yeah because if the men you
want want to do you'd be with them yeah
and but it's like somehow that's
offensive just like the same way that if
if the girls like if you're not having
sex like the women you want aren't
sleeping with you yeah and it's it's
it's it's it's but the thing is though
even though I think women are much more
likely to do a lot of self-development
work on themselves oh I disagree from
what I've seen a lot of men
self-development is this it's journaling
it's plastic surgery
um it's healing which never includes
actual therapy and if it does it's
short-lived and not consistent you know
I vehemently
engage in it more men are a lot more
stubbornness in mind in terms of
coaching men men tend to be a lot more
stubborn but I think they're a lot more
realistic I think sometimes women can be
a lot more deluded about the actual real
world so taking all this action but it
may not like you said like let me look
at myself men tend to be a lot more
stubborn though about doing that work
for themselves that's the difference I
think if both can tweak it women need to
be a lot more realistic about the world
you're right if you're not getting the
guides you want you need to look at
yourself so it's not the men you need
and it's all it's okay whereas men tend
to do it after the horse is bolted that
you know men will do after say the
marriage is failed or after something's
gone wrong then they start like that's
what I mean like when when I have men
like ask me about you know whatever DM
me message me and if I give them advice
like they'll come back in a month or two
months later and have actually improved
where it's like women it's just not the
same they I never they do but look at
the stats with men though you know the
statue of men are getting worse you know
one-third of men I think it's just five
and six men are being divorced I think
it's because men just don't think the
juice is worth the squeeze anymore it's
like it's like they do all this and what
do they get on the other side if mentor
on mass they would change the world
that's what men don't get but men truly
demanded a certain level of behavior
they'll change you but men are falling
for the first trap they're hitting up
these girls with likes and they're
telling you women they're amazing
actually creating the very well but I'm
saying that they compare it starts it
the women start it because they start
with the Thirsty I don't see a second I
don't sorry to interrupt you by the way
I don't see as men against women I'm
just saying what kind of world do you
want to create a dual action in
alignment with the world you want to
create but my point is that like I think
the women need to start before the man
but what if they don't then what are you
gonna do I mean I mean I think like it's
gonna more and more men are gonna be
sexual and I think I think it's actually
going to be in a world where there's
more relationships like this to be
honest
thanks for something no no but
statistically there can only be a few of
you that do yeah the stats won't eat but
that's the point is that more and more
men will be sexless the trend is heading
that way so what does that mean the rest
of us are sharing I think more and more
women will be childless I think 50
probably yeah number 30 will be single
and childless and that's what so I think
if women don't improve that's the future
that we're going to see I wanted to
comment on the the rejection thing so
like what I found over 10 years of
coaching this stuff now is that most
guys have this unrealistic expectation
that they want every girl to like them
so I tell them like if you were cold
calling in sales or you were knocking
doors it doesn't matter if you're the
best salesman in the world you're going
to encounter people that just tell you
to [__] off or they're going to tell you
I'm not interested and a lot of those
things are outside your control like
there exists girls that have boyfriends
and husbands that don't want to cheat
when you talk to them in the club
there's girls that are in a bad mood
they don't like you for whatever reason
instead of taking that personally and
thinking I suck think okay that one's
just not interested this one probably
will but most men get deflated and then
they bring that negative energy into the
next interaction and then that causes
them to get rejected with a higher
chance it'd be hard not to I mean I
worked in sales I sold the copiers and
I'm telling you there's nothing worse
than selling it you just like to sell
like a stand-up ten thousand dollar copy
machine
who wants that and I'm like I I can't
even imagine because when I did that job
it was so soul sucking yeah that I'm
like go getting rejected and that
contributes to the problem right because
the guys have to develop almost like an
emotional resilience yeah yeah you have
to or you just have like this thick skin
and you just know that when you hit
those girls that are interested there's
going to be other girls that are
interested and but a lot of guys will
take it personally I get clients they'll
go up get two or three rejections and
then just give up and they stop
approaching for the night so what's
what's your advice to men that want to
overcome their fear of rejection well I
tell them to follow uh the old school
three second rule right so you have less
than three seconds to go in once you see
the attractive girl and then assume it's
going to go well and if it doesn't don't
take it personally and I give them
strategies for how to open properly like
with direct eye contact speaking loud
enough smiling Etc versus like coming in
Meek and passive and this and that so I
give them chances to give or give them
strategies give them the best chances
but then also be realistic about the
fact that it's not going to work out
with some girls no matter how good you
get no matter how high value you get or
anything there's still gonna be girls
who don't like you and there's coaches
that are like when you get good enough
there's no more rejections that's false
or they're you're never gonna get flaked
on a date it's like really people don't
have things come up with their schedule
so these are just part of the game
people have to be able to just deal with
those things and not take it super
personally what about the ladies what's
your advice that to men that want to
overcome their fear of rejection I
haven't heard too much from you
okay I want to hear from these three
first I feel like the more that you do
something the more confidence you'll
have when you do it like rejection is
not always rejection I like the phrase
rejection is redirection so it's like
just do it there's a quote I don't know
what it's like it's like confidence is
the amount of times you do something
okay or something like that basically
just do it just try to put yourself out
there what's a good opening line and I
want the guys to say if you think these
are good that a guy should use to a girl
I want the dating coaches to read it
let's see I don't know I'll have ribs
like that I like
I'm joking
um I like winter grasses
um
um okay I like on that guy says hi
excuse me you're looking really
beautiful today
um or say hi
um how are you did it like something
like that I don't know I like I like to
be complimented like oh oh do you need
help with it I don't know if they see me
doing something oh oh what are you doing
here today I don't know like nice not
like
forward like so the good opening line is
high you look very beautiful today how
are you yeah yeah no no how you look
very beautiful today like
like what's your name like where are you
from like oh do you mind if I could um
good or bad uh it depends on like you
know if he's like kissing your ass or
like supplicator and like that but if
it's just like a nice comment I think
that's fun yeah yeah now that you ask me
I think I'm part of the problem that
we're talking about because if a guy was
to move to me on the street I wouldn't
take him seriously for sure that's the
thing yeah I think I would just assume
that he does that with everyone but he's
single so yeah
it's a bit crazy
it depends I mean like was like London
digging guys were like hello I thought
you were hot and like that and they're
just doing that like in Mass right yeah
that's why he said it depends on how you
say it that's a nice thing my opener for
10 years has just been I want to meet
you real quick it's like very direct I
wanted to meet you and you say like when
they're like yeah yes that's that's the
way but I hope pedestal oh my God you're
beautiful how many times did you have
that no no like that but like you're
putting it on a kind of level of oh my
God you're so beautiful I'm not used to
now because hey how's it going what's
your name how's it going it depends on
the frame of how it comes across like
you don't want a guy that comes up wow
you're like the most amazing you don't
want that she's like oh I just saw you
like I thought you look really beautiful
like you know what are you doing around
here like what are you doing today I
like that kind of thing
what are you what's your advice to you
guys and what's your opening line My
love language My love language is acts
of service so if it's something very
simple as let me get that for you as
he's opening the doors my knees start to
go weak or even yeah or even at the bars
like let me get that for you I'm just
like okay all right it's like uh Waller
just don't open doors for girls
I still believe in that
um but also with me I'm very I'm a
person that's very aware and I also know
that rejection is very hard so if a guy
does take does approach me I know it's
taken him a lot to be able to do that so
I'm not going to reject him and be rude
and say oh I'm not interested I'm going
to go with the flow of the conversation
and I'll let him down gently but I think
it also what you were saying that you're
the problem it takes us to be as human
beings to be empathetic as well to
understand that he's still a human he
does still have feelings it has taken a
lot for him to approach you so just be
nice yeah for sure so what do you think
of her I like that that's quite natural
isn't let me get the door for hey where
you have to yeah her name how's it going
yeah
I don't know
you cannot be I don't like anything
that's like all like contrived and I
mean that's not gonna even happen that
often right like in terms of like
situation depending but you can look for
a daughter I think just starting the
conversation and being direct as long as
there's not like fancy gaming gimmicky
stuff then that's thumbs up for me okay
what about you what's your advice to man
what's a pickup line that you like I
don't have like a specific pickup line
but I'd say become evident not arrogant
and be just be straightforward what's
the difference between confidence and
arrogance well I feel like in the
context
I feel like with the context that we're
talking about you don't want to come off
as I know I'm coming to get you and I'm
getting you and I'm I've got you did you
get one do you know what I'm doing okay
no I think I think confidence is I don't
mind getting rejected but if you reject
me I'll walk off like a man and I won't
oh you're dead anyway or you know oh
that's the worst of a guy yeah he's mad
yeah okay thing though yeah like for
example no yeah that's that just to you
and that happens in sales too right I
don't know if you saw that in sales but
I did sales for a summer and just see
how it translates to game and there's
like rookies that go up to the door and
they the guy slams the door on their
face and they're like yelling stuff at
the guy or it's like a veteran who's
like okay that person's not interested
and they don't take it personally yeah
versus like trying to get even no in the
UK guys take it personally they'll be
like oh you're ugly anyway
but that's young guys
I don't find it that common I just here
and there yeah yeah yeah I don't know it
depends
um so did you have a line or no I don't
have a line but I'd say me personally I
like it when a guy starts off with a
compliment but not an obvious compliment
not anything to do with my face whether
it be something about my style or the
way I carry myself oh so if I get a
compliments your style yeah something
yeah good or bad
that's good yeah that's cool okay uh
what about you yeah usually like I start
complimenting this style or something
that because like if I'm approach a
person like uh for sure it's because
there's something that I'm interested in
that person I don't know if they
approach you
oh yeah well I'm approaching approaching
you what okay so yeah so tell me why you
approached me oh I think you're really
cool yeah like you see me really cool
what's your name oh can you talk oh
let's think fun facts okay that's a
compliment still yeah do you like that
one yeah I mean as long as it got like
the biggest problem I've seen is that
like a lot of coaches say like come in
and say oh you look like you like this
or like you know just say really cheesy
fancy gimmicky stuff where they're like
using lines or like you know these these
clever pickup lines or like different
stuff like that and that just has like
this air of like this is a a little
tactic that I'm trying to win you over
with yeah like all the common theme
between all the responses is they want
the guy to be like genuine and actually
like showing he's interested without
hiding it right like guys that come up
and ask you for directions like it's
obvious that they don't want directions
yeah but like you like lose maybe a
little respect because he's not having
the balls to be straightforward and
that's the iron if you think about it
you only get good at that if you deal
with rejection right because it's almost
the emotional calibration and you have
to deal with the rejection to get that
inward that didn't work well that didn't
work with that type of woman so you have
to do that in order to have the hey
how's it going how are you doing that's
the beauty of rejection what's your line
my line oh
um
yo what's happening
every London guy ever is that what he
said pretty much I did I did yeah yeah I
have to own that but also I want you
approached him yeah okay how what line
did you use
it wasn't really a line it was an
ultimatum a little bit if you don't want
me there's lots of men doing she really
played the kind of manipulation with it
we were good friends for a long time
though to be honest I've seen him did
you friend zone him or did she friend
zone you no no one friends only travel
when I first saw I was in a relationship
so and then we just became friends we
were doing a lot of the same coaching
and self-development together and then
when I got single she kind of did the
ultimatum look you better take me now
because you don't someone else will want
me
you know but for the minute I first saw
it it was just like love at first sight
but I wasn't a relationship that's crazy
how long until you dumped the that's not
I'm assuming you dumped it no I didn't
he did the girl because of her it just
didn't work out well yeah dump her if it
was I thought it was right because
where I met at a contest I met her we
were doing a lot of self-development
training we had a massive um
self-development country
um uh company and integrity was a very
important thing in terms of the training
we were doing and I had to learn that
because I've come from a culture of just
chatting up girls willy-nilly right but
I still never really believe in cheating
necessarily I'm avoids because my
parents have been married for 60 plus
years I've always believed the monogamy
and the rest of it but from an Integrity
point of view I was already in a
relationship so straight away I'm not
gonna even go there I can acknowledge oh
my God she's beautiful that's exactly
the kind of woman I want to be with but
because of my situation I was like I'm
not going anywhere near there and when
it naturally ended and I was single and
we were friends for ages she then made
the move and I was like hell yeah I'm up
for it because for the minute I met you
you were perfect you know fair or man as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demand monetized on
a daily basis on this platform if you
want to help please consider sending a
super thanks below every donation helps
and it helps make what we do possible